but I shad von weizsäcker was a
political president through and through
the words of incumbent German President
URM vulc he was touching on what was
perhaps vite sechas most important
address in 1985 when he described the
end of the Second World War as a day of
liberation for Germans we had fun vatika
Vashti Nick no intellect way but the
chef on white secor wasn't just
intellectually aware of what Germany had
lost in terms of dictatorship genocide
and war Suzanne me experienced it during
his own entire life and with his family
history vielleicht farad SP perhaps
that's why he felt and let's not be shy
to say it a calling to urge us Germans
to finally confront the war and its
consequences you bet in creeks Ongina
phone superheavy gowk said that
throughout his lengthy political career
von weizsäcker had always been a source
of inspiration and orientation for
Germans in deems EE Martin by liking him
Germans learn to like themselves it was
Highlanders he brought something of a
healing process to political life if her
nylons for the headphone vine we bow
before the HUD phone white zeca a great
president who could be relied on to say
the right thing and do the right thing
as HD is active want to switch to get
hard foreign minister frank-walter
Steinmeier also paid tribute to fajn
white zeca as one of Germany's greatest
diplomats we get one bites occur had
David noise for the headphone white zeca
gave not only our Eastern neighbors but
the whole world a new faith in our
country Vida governess for that restored
faith was essential on a path to
reunification savedoff and our nation
still thrives on that faith today
Poseidon he said white zeca was a man of
morals of dialogue and of peace nista
mean Nick League neat swung events
should be shaped not with armies not
with war not with force but with words
and such hope is so vital
these tumultuous times in the hydrogen
skirmish but Wally hand side following
the state funeral the HUD phone white
seka is being laid to rest in a West
Berlin cemetery in a small service
attended by family